[Musique]
c'est une institution de la rue
Sainte-Catherine le chapelier Henri
Henry souffle ses 90 bougies cette année
si on continue par ici on a les statues
un inventaire de 15000 chapeaux dont les
prix varient entre 150 et quelques
milliers de dollars ce n'est pas le
choix qui manque ici quelqu'un qui nous
dit j'ai pas une tête à chapeau
pour nous c'est un gros défi puis
habituellement il sort d'ici très
satisfait et donc ça ça sert à quoi ça
sert à prendre la forme de votre tête
pour une pièce unique les clients
s'offriront du sur-mesure un service
élargi cette année avec la rénovation de
l'atelier de voir que c'est aussi
populaire ça c'est vraiment
une passion c'est intéressant
Sylvain l'abbé a fait ses classes à
l'Opéra de Paris puis au Cirque du
Soleil l'artisan chapelier est manipule
des instruments tout droit sortis du
siècle dernier on se croirait dans un
musée où les feutres les plus fins sont
moulés dans l'histoire entre la boutique
90 ans donc ils ont peut-être plus que
100 ans ou certains en tout cas donc de
dire que moi j'ai encore accès à ça il y
a quelque chose
un peu magique et c'est un peu la
signature du marchand de chapeau toutes
les meubles de chez Henri Henri date de
1932 l'enseigne est gravé dans
l'histoire de la métropole dans les
années 1950 la boutique offre un chapeau
gratuit aux joueurs de hockey qui marque
3 buts dans une partie
un grand coup de publicité l'expression
tour du chapeau est ainsi popularisé
chez les Canadiens français donc des
joueurs comme babéoles Philippe posito
gorléar Maurice Richard Jean Béliveau et
bien d'autres sont ici au magasin
chercher leur chapeau là ils vont
certainement
le chapeau va revenir ici c'est des
chapeaux plus de style steampunk les
hautes formes son fils puisse dans la
culture populaire pour renouveler la
collection avec des chapeaux plus
contemporains présentement
les clients beaucoup le chapeau de
cow-boy ça peut être une série comme
Peaky blinders qui vont prendre beaucoup
de casquettes on essaie de s'adapter
vraiment vraiment aux clients à cheval
entre le passé et l'avenir c'est avec la
vente en ligne que Henri Henry va tenter
de réussir son prochain tour du chapeau
ici Jean-Philippe Radio-Canada MONT